la chronique culture avec Johanna soudri
comme tous les mercredis bonsoir Joanna
bonsoir WIF on par festival du cinéma
d'animation fête du cinéma d'animation
tout d'abord oui alors pour en parler
avec nous et bien deux personnes sur ce
plateau je commence par par les dames
par la dame Mariline Mariline pou vous
êtes la référente jeune public au cinéma
Les Yeux d'Elsa à saint-ciè l'école et à
côté de vous et bien j'allais dire le
directeur mais il faut dire responsable
du cinéma Les Yeux d'Elsa toujours à
saint-c l'école bien sûr donc vous allez
un petit peu nous parler de des
animations que vous allez organiser à
l'occasion de cette 11e fête du cinéma
d'animation avant de parler de ce qui va
être fait directement au cinéma de les
yeux d' j'aimerais bien savoir un petit
peu quelle est l'historique de de ce
festival enfin de cette fête puisque
c'est déjà la 11e édition donc ça ça
remonte à plusieurs années je me tourne
vers vous Bertrand Pinier vous êtes un
peu le spécialiste sur la question euh
ben je oui enfin en quelque sorte on va
dire ça comme ça oui euh en fait c'est
c'est donc en effet la 11e édition de la
de la la fête nation enfin de la oui de
la fête nationale du cinéma d'animation
euh mais enfin voilà c'est c'est pour
fêter donc voilà c'est le cinéma
d'animation à 120 ans cette année pu
mais c'est quoi exactement le cinéma
d'animation ben le cinéma d'animation
pour tout le monde c'est les dessins
animés d'abord et tout le monde en
connaît et tout le monde en regarde tous
les jours à la télévision
évidemment c'est c'est aussi l'animation
d'objets l'animation de de volume votre
stylo on pourrait le faire s'animer tout
seul je pense que plein de gens ont déjà
vu des des films qui qui enfin voilà qui
F pr une photo en gros d'un objet d'un
dessin et ensuite une autre et une autre
et c'est le principe du cinéma oui le
principe du cinéma c'est 24 images par
seconde c'est ça ex avz découvert
comment fonctionner le cinéma voilà pas
la seule ce soir d'ailleurs c'est
beaucoup plus facile à dire qu'à faire
évidemment mais le voilà en fait le
principe c'est que donc il y a 24 images
par seconde donc on on prend une image
puis on déplace l'objet on on reprend
unihoto et cetera et ça 12 fois par
seconde puisque l'œil perd enfin voilà
l'œil accepte bien que que ce ne soit
pas 24 fois par seconde mais 12 fois par
seconde très technique ouais donc cette
fête démarre dans quelques jours le 20
octobre pour s'achever le 31 octobre et
donc vous au cinéma Les Yeux d'Elsa vous
prévoyez pour mercredi prochain donc le
24 samedi 27 et dimanche 28 des cinémas
ciné goûter atelier avec donc des des
sessions différentes selon les âges
d'abord mercredi et samedi des
rendez-vous pour les le jeune public
c'est ça maréine oui alors l'idée là de
mercredi et samedi c'est de de proposer
donc en avant-première inédite donc en
France et dans le département du coup on
sera les seuls à passer ce programme
c'est la petite fabrique du monde un
programme donc qui vient juste de sortir
à partir de 3 ans donc avec plein de
films donc on parlait d'animation là
c'est vraiment l'animation de toutes les
matières il y a du tissu il y a de la
neig du sable et cetera c'est très très
bon on a des photos je pense qu'on
pourra peut-être les voir tout à l'heure
c'est fait en tissu brillant et c'est
c'est magnifique ou il y il y a il y a
donc vraiment toute une variété de de
matière qui est animée qu'on voit ça
c'est la création du monde donc en tissu
et l'idée donc avec avec cette
projection on propose donc un goûter
après le film et puis un atelier on va
s'amuser à fabriquer un petit film
d'animation
donc en pixilation donc avec ça veut
dire
ça ou image par image pour aller plus
vite mais on aimerait bien faire ça avec
les enfants enfin que eux-mêmes se
prennent en photo et puis et du coup
enfin c'est très vite magique en fait il
suffit de faire quelques mouvements et
et on ça s'anime et donc c'est c'est
voilà c'est le donc en fait c'est les
enfants qui vont s'animer tout se voilà
et en fait c'est la pixilation c'est un
petit côté saccadé en fait c'est pas
très fluide comme l'animation qu'on peut
voir dessin animés et cetera voilà c'est
technique mais bon ça sera pas tellement
technique ça va être surtout ludique
donc c'est rendez-vous participatif
voilà on va pas être passif si on vient
participer à cette fête du cinéma
d'animation exactement l'idée c'est de
c'est de créer aussi les enfants ont
quel âge c'est alors le programme il est
accessible à partir de 3 ans pour les
ateliers 3 ans c'est un petit peu juste
donc à partir de de 4 4 ans ça commence
ça commence à être bien si les enfants
sont accompagnés évidemment des parents
c'est mieux mais c'est pas la garderie
Vous allez pas faire garderie c'est pas
c'est pas l'objectif je vous vois B non
surtout pas c'est encore mieux quand il
y a des Frat qu des frères s ensemble
quand quand les les enfants peuvent
interagir ensemble et devenir un vrai
groupe voilà et créer les choses qu'ils
ont vraiment envie de créer donc le
dimanche 28 octobre c'est la journée
mondiale justement du cinéma d'animation
et également une journée spéciale pour
les plus grands alors là si vous voulez
bien on va regarder tout de suite la
bande annonce du film les enfants loup
et puis on en parle juste après très
bien donc pour cette bande annonce de ce
film àffiche dans le cadre de la Fête du
cinéma d'animation àens lesco ça c'est
pour les plus grands à partir de quel
âge on peut voir ce film à partir de à
partir de 8 ou 10 ans mais le la le
choix qu'on a fait sur la journée du du
dimanche c'est de faire une journée
spécialement sur le cinéma d'animation
japonais parce que c'est un cinéma qui
est souvent connu et bien bien que
méconnu en fait enfin voilà on a
beaucoup on entend beaucoup parler mais
on sait pas forcément exactement d'où ça
vient ce que c'est et l'idée c'est de
présenter deux films ant de ces
dernières années donc les enfants loup
amé Yuki de mamouro au soda qui est
sorti récemment et puis colorful de
kaishiara qui est sorti l'année dernière
il y a y a tout pile un an et qui a un
film qui qui est passé relativement
inaperçu et qui pourtant propose une
très belle histoire sur l'adolescence
sur voilà le autour de la question du
suicide mais sans être jamais ni ni
morose ni pathétique ni dur ça pour les
8 100 ans le suicide et ben ça peut le
paraître évidemment quand on dit suicide
évidemment ça c'est au secours et et en
fait non puisque le traitement est
vraiment un traitement extrêmement
positif les Japonais ont cette capacit
ité à à toujours proposer des choses
motivantes et même en mettant les
personnages dans les situations les plus
horribles possibles les personnages vont
réussir malgré tout par la force de leur
volonté par leur intelligence ou par
d'autres qualités à avancer et à avancer
positivement et c'est aussi ce que j'ai
envie de ce que j'avais envie de voilà
de de mettre en avant dans cette journée
ces deux films seront projetés avec
entre les deux films un petit atelier à
nouveau une petite conférence un peu
c'est ça une sorte de conférence animée
alors on dit pas conférence parce que ça
fait peur aux gens mais en fait c'est ça
in l'idée c'est c'est de présenter
l'éventail de ce qui s'est fait depuis
depuis les années 40 au Japon en
animation puisque on s'arrête souvent à
Albator golderac Dragon Ball or ben il y
a un personnage magique qui s'appelle
Astro qui a été inventé il y a
extrêmement longtemps qui était repris à
plusieurs reprises et puis il y a plein
d'autres choses qui ont été faites qui
sont vraiment superbes toutes et et
c'est important aussi je pense de voilà
de remettre un petit peu d'histoire dans
tout ça et tout ça est à découvrir donc
à sain-è l'école le programme est très
complet merci à tous les deux d'être
venu sur ce plateau